quand nous avons commencé à parler de ce film
en termes d'aventure, une
séquence d'action dans un train était quelque chose que
nous avions toujours voulu faire,
nous voulions nous appuyer sur les
films précédents et appliquer toutes ces connaissances à
quelque chose de pratique et réel et et
amener cette séquence de train à un autre
niveau
il n'y avait pas un surplus de trains
disponibles pour être détruits nous devions construire
le train si nous voulions le détruire
pour le tirer pratiquement c'était extrêmement
difficile
non seulement à exécuter mais aussi à concevoir
tous les différents trains  des voitures et cela
pourrait en fait fonctionner sur une voie ferrée en état de marche
personne d'autre au monde ne fait ce
niveau de réalisation de films pratiques et cela ne se reproduira peut-être plus jamais la
séquence de train nous emmène dans une aventure
absolument énorme nous avons ce grand
combat sur le toit en cours  60 miles à l'heure
à travers une vraie vallée,
j'ai fait des scènes de combat mais pour les faire dans
un train en mouvement, c'était un procès par le feu, c'est
comme ça que Tom aime faire des choses,
il va maintenant me sortir du train
quand tu es suspendu à un train  Carriage
Tom est une personne formidable à avoir à vos côtés
non seulement il est intrépide, il
cherche toujours à voir comment ça va atterrir
pour le public
chaque caméra qui a
tiré exactement une seule fois pour bien faire les choses, pas
seulement une question de déclenchement parce que si nous
faisons tout, nous ne le capturons pas correctement
à quoi bon
[Musique]
tout ce que vous voyez dans cette
séquence de train spectaculaire est fait pour
investir  le public de ces personnages
Mission Impossible est la
franchise d'aventure la plus extraordinaire que vous ayez
jamais vue,
vous pouvez le faire avec une équipe comme celle-ci et
avec un acteur comme Tom
[Musique]